- They say that when you first
open a can of surströmming,
it's one of the worst smells in the world.
- Let's not do it then.
- I don't want to. Oh!
- Oh!
- You've broken the seal.
- Oh, God!
- Okay, nope.
- I'm not.
- Oh God, no!
- Okay, all right.
- [Voiceover] Oh my God.
(people retching)
- [Voiceover] It's sewage.
It's sewage in a can.
- [Voiceover] Oh my God
- [Voiceover] I'm out.
- [Voiceover] Can we leave?
- [Voiceover] It's so bad.
- [Voiceover] Oh, it's
coming, it's traveling!
- [Voiceover] Oh!
- [Voiceover] It's traveling!
- [Voiceover] Oh God.
Someone turn on the air!
- I have the worst gag reflex.
I'm definitely gonna heave.
(retches)
- It's one of the worst things
I've ever smelled in my life,
and I can't wait to get out of here.
- I smelled this from
outside the building.
- I don't see how you
can eat this indoors.
- There's a lot of
terrible smells in there.
- It's like fish.
- Baby diaper.
- Cheese.
- Durian, the fruit.
- And dead body.
- It smells like foreskin.
- And all these things got together
and they were like, "Hey, let's hang out!"
- Like regret, like you smell regret.
- And it's weird because
you smell it at first,
and you're like, "Oh, that smells bad."
- It's like a national park bathroom
that somebody just dumped
a bunch of dog food in.
- Then another smell
kicks in, and you're like,
"Oh, that really smells bad."
- No, it smells like
dook. It smells like poo.
- Then another one kicks in,
and you're like, "I'm done."
(retches)
- Have people been puking?
- (retches) I can taste it already!
(retches) I can't even look at it!
- The tin looks like it's left over
from World War II, honestly.
(knife clatters)
- Holy shit.
- I think it's just in a
soup of its own fermentation.
- (retches) No, no, I thought there were
gonna be pieces, it's just soup!
- Oh, it looks like a booger!
- It's dripping gray juice.
- This doesn't look like a real color.
- Vomit.
(retching)
- It looks like when you walk by a sewer,
muck and bacteria that has congealed.
- Taking it out and putting it on
a plate intensified the smell.
- Has anyone eaten this actually?
(fork clatters)
- Nope, not doing it. Sorry guys.
You gotta draw the line somewhere.
- (fork clatters) It's worse, it's worse
than you think it's gonna be.
- It does not taste even a
quarter as bad as it smells.
- It tastes very briny, extremely salty.
- You know, I still don't
want to eat more of it.
I kind of just want to
get out of this room.
- I can imagine this
probably tastes better
with side dishes or maybe
rolled up in something.
(fork clatters)
- What the fuck is this,
and where is it from?
And how do I never have this again?
- (spitting) Scratch
that off the bucket list!
- I feel like the smell is so overwhelming
that it's informing my
taste buds to not like it.
- (retches) Do I have to swallow it?
- No. No, I don't want to.
- There's kind of a really clean
fish taste in my mouth at this point.
At the very beginning, it was,
I don't even know what that taste was.
(retches)
- Why is it hairy?
- And there are definitely bones in it.
Should I stick this
whole thing in my mouth?
- How could this be more heinous?
(retches)
It is the worst thing I've ever eaten,
the worst thing I've ever
smelled or put in my mouth.
And I am not exaggerating.
- That is the weirdest thing in the world.
- It's awful. Ugh!
- The coolest thing about this
is that it's pretty badass
if you enjoy it and eat it.
I mean, not many people in the world,
I think, could stomach this.
- Yeah, my final thought is that
I never want to have this again.
So let's close it, and close
this chapter on our lives.
(can lid scraping)
Together.
- It's something that's
culturally sensitive,
and people should respect that
someone out there eats this and enjoys it.
They must have very, very limited access
to their sense of smell because
it is the worst food I've ever smelled.